N
AMERICA.
WE WILL PLAY THE FULL VIDEO, YOU
DON'T WANT TO MISS IT.
BUT FIRST, WE START TONIGHT,
PRESIDENT SIPPY CUP, YOUR
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN, PROBABLY
RESTING COMFORTABLY AFTER HIS
BIG SUMMIT WITH VLADIMIR, AS
PREDICTED BY ANY OBJECTIVE
MEASURE, THE MEETING WAS AN
ORDER TRAIN WRECK.
PUTIN BASICALLY GAVE JOE
NOTHING.
THE UNITED STATES NOTHING.
HE MADE NOT A SINGLE CONCESSION.
THERE WERE ZERO AGREEMENTS AND
AFTER THE MEETING, PUTIN HELD A
SOLO PRESS CONFERENCE WHERE,
LET'S SEE, HE MOCKED AND TRASHED
THE U.S. AT LENGTH AND BIDEN
GAVE A SHORT, SCRIPTED SPEECH,
PROBABLY WRITTEN BEFORE THE
SUMMIT, TOOK A HANDFUL OF
QUESTIONS FROM, AS ALWAYS,
PRESELECTED REPORTERS AND THEN
GOT VERY CRANKY AND LASHED OUT
AT REPORTERS.
IT TENDS TO HAPPEN WHEN YOU
DON'T GET YOUR WARM MILKY.
EVEN STEPHEN COLBERT, RADICAL
THAT HE IS BRUTALLY MOCKING
GRANDPA JOE LAST NIGHT BUT DON'T
WORRY BECAUSE JOE PROUDLY
ANNOUNCED THAT HE PRESENTED
PUTIN WITH A LIST -- PAY
ATTENTION HERE, THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
16 CRITICAL AREAS OF AMERICAN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT VLADIMIR AND
THE RUSSIANS BETTER NOT TARGET
WITH A CYBER ATTACK.
THAT INCLUDES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS, FOOD AND
ENERGY.
FIRST POINT, HOW DUMB IS IT TO
GIVE A HOSTILE ACT OR AN EVIL
GUY LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN 16
SPECIFIC THINGS, A ROAD MAP THAT
WOULD CRIPPLE THE USA?
THAT'S PRETTY DUMB.
SECOND.
RUSSIA HAS ALREADY LAUNCHED JUST
IN RECENT WEEKS, NOT ONE, BUT
TWO CYBERATTACKS AGAINST OUR
ENERGY SECTOR AND OUR FOOD
SECTOR AND BIDEN, HE DIDN'T
RESPOND IN ANY WAY.
SO, QUESTION, WHAT WOULD STOP
PUTIN FROM GOING AFTER THE OTHER
14 SECTORS?
AND THIRD, ALL CYBERATTACKS
AGAINST AMERICA AND AMERICANS --
JOE, THAT ALREADY SHOULD BE
OFF-LIMITS.
YOU SHOULD HAVE LECTURED HIM
LOUDLY.
THERE SHOULD BE CONSEQUENCES,
NOT WAIVERS TO BUILD PIPELINES.
REALLY, REALLY DUMB, EVEN FOR
BIDEN.
BUT AS PER USUAL, THE MOB, THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE TRYING SO HARD
TO KEEP THE BIDEN PROTECTION
PROGRAM GOING.
STARTING TO SEE CRACKS HERE AND
THERE, EVEN LATE-NIGHT COMICS
ARE BEGINNING TO REALIZE THIS
GUY IS NOT REALLY WITH US, IS
HE?
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING AFTER
MEETING PUTIN, A BIDEN RATE
SHOWS ITSELF AGAIN.
STUBBORN OPTIMISM, AND LOOK AT
THIS, FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," BIDEN
WIPED THE SMIRK OFF PUTIN'S
FACE.
YEAH, OKAY.
OF COURSE THE HIGH PRIEST
CONTINUED ON FAKE NEWS TD
NETWORKS ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I CAN'T THINK OF A MORE
SUCCESSFUL DIPLOMAT A TRIP IN
THE 21ST CENTURY THAN THIS ONE.
>> MY INSIGHT WASHING THE PRESS
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY WAS THERE
WAS A KIND OF POETRY IN HIS
PROSE.
>> I THINK THAT THIS CONTRAST
THAT WE SAW TODAY BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS AN ATTEMPT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO SAY
LOOK, WE ARE THE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM.
>> AND I THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS
THE MAN OF THE MOMENT AND YES,
HE TURNED ON CAITLIN COLLINS.
FINE FOR A MOMENT AND THEN HE
APOLOGIZED.
HE IS SUCH A NICE GUY COMING
DID YOU EVER ONCE HERE TRUMP
APOLOGIZED TO A REPORTER?
>> IT'S OF INTERESTING POSTURE.
AT ONE POINT I WROTE
PROFESSOR BIDEN BECAUSE I
THOUGHT HE WAS TRYING TO
BASICALLY BE ABOVE IT.
THE ABOVE THE MEETING AND
EXPLAIN, LOOK, GUYS, KEEPS
PLAYING A GAME.
>> Sean: I'M HAVING A REALLY
HARD TIME NOT REACH INTO MY
LEFT, PICKING UP THIS TRASH
BARREL RIGHT HERE AND PUKING IN
IT.
FOX NEWS CNN'S JEFF ALAN, HE
CONTINUED ON TWITTER WRITING
"JOE BIDEN CARRIED HIMSELF WITH
A SEASONED AIR OF CONFIDENCE
THAT NEW PRESIDENTS SELDOM
POSSESS."
CNN REPORTER HAD AWARE MOMENT OF
HONESTY THOUGH HOWEVER BECAUSE
HE DID GO AFTER KAITLAN COLLINS,
HE WAS VERY MEAN TO HER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT WE'VE NOT SEEN HIM DO IS
ANSWER QUESTIONS LIKE THAT
WITHOUT HIS AIDES SCREAMING AT
HIM TO STOP.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A PRESIDENT
COVERING THE LAST FOUR OF THEM
WHO IS SO PROTECTED BY HIS AIDES
IN TERMS OF OFTEN NOT WANTING
HIM TO ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS.
THEY WERE SILENT TODAY.
>> Sean: JEFF, TAKE IT TO THE
NEXT LEVEL.
WHY ARE THEY CONTROLLING HIM?
I'M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE IF I
TAKE ANOTHER QUESTION.
I CAN'T TAKE ANOTHER QUESTION.
WHY?
BECAUSE HIS OWN STAFF KNOWS HE'S
NOT CAPABLE OF GETTING A
COHERENT ANSWER.
ANYONE WITH COMMON SENSE KNOWS
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
JOE BIDEN GETS AGITATED AT THE
DROP OF A HAT, HE GETS CRANKY
WITHOUT HIS WARM MILKY AND A
SIPPY CUP, FREQUENTLY FORGETS
WHAT HE IS SAYING MIDSENTENCE.
AT TIMES HE SEEMS TOTALLY LOST,
DAZED, AND CONFUSED AND THAT'S
WHY SIPPY CUP STAFF PREVENTS
THEM FROM ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS, BECAUSE THEY HATE
CLEANING UP THE MESS THAT HE
MAKES AND TONIGHT OUR COUNTRY
NEEDS A CAPABLE LEADER, NOT A
MUMBLING, BUMBLING IDIOT.
AMERICA IS FACING SERIOUS
PROBLEMS, THE CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, IT'S REAL.
AT THE RISING THREAT OF CHINA,
IRAN, RUSSIA, WAR IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, SPIKING INFLATION.
BY THE WAY, RIGHTLY SO, 70% OF
AMERICANS THINK BIDEN'S POLICIES
ARE MAKING IT WORSE AND OF
COURSE INFLATION IS NOT, WELL, A
CONCERN FOR THE BIG GUY BECAUSE
THE BIDEN FAMILY SYNDICATE
BUSINESS, THAT'S BOOMING.
IT ZERO EXPERIENCE-HUNTER IS NOW
AN
ARTIST AND DESPITE NO FORMAL
TRAINING, NO DEGREE, NO
EXPERIENCE, NO TALENT EVEN,
UNDER'S PAINTINGS ARE EXPECTED
TO FETCH UP TO $500,000 APIECE.
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE THEY WILL
CALL IT PORTRAITS OF A CRACKHEAD
TURNED TO POLITICAL INFLUENCE
PEDDLING.
THE BUYERS WILL REMAIN
ANONYMOUS, OF COURSE.
GOT TO KEEP UP THIS PAY TO PLAY
SCHEME THEY'VE GOT GOING.
HUNTER ONCE AGAIN IS SELLING
ACCESS, JUST LIKE HE DID WITH
UKRAINE WITH NO EXPERIENCE, JUST
LIKE THE $1.5 BILLION DEAL WITH
THE BANK OF CHINA, THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SHOPPING SPREE.
HOW MANY OF US GET UNDER
THOUSAND DOLLARS SHOPPING SPREE
WITH A CHINESE NATIONAL?
AND DON'T FORGET THE MONEY FROM
RUSSIA, THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS WITH THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH, FORMER FIRST LADY OF
MOSCOW, AND THE CATHOLIC
OLIGARCHS BUT HE GOT MONEY FROM.
JOE BIDEN JUST CLAIM -- THINK
ABOUT THIS, TOO CORRUPT TO BE AT
NATO BUT APPARENTLY NOT CORRUPT
FOR HIS SON TO DO BUSINESS AND
MAKE MILLIONS WITH UKRAINE OR
FOR HIM TO DEMAND THAT THEY FIRE
A PROSECUTOR OR THEY'RE NOT
GETTING HER TAX DOLLARS.
WOW, THAT WHOLE THING SEEMS
CORRUPT.
NO LEGITIMATE PERSON, NO ENTITY
WOULD EVER PAY HUNTER BIDEN A
SINGLE PENNY FOR HIS EXPERTISE
IN ANYTHING.
HIS ART I'M SURE IS NOT THAT
GOOD.
HUNTER IS A LONGTIME DEGENERATE,
BANNED FROM A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOTEL.
WHY?
SMOKING CRACK.
ALLEGEDLY KICKED OUT OF THE D.C.
STRIP CLUB.
IT'S KIND OF HARD, I WOULD
IMAGINE, TO GET KICKED OUT OF A
STRIP CLUB.
I'M JUST GUESSING, I DON'T GO.
FOR WHAT?
OH, SMOKING CRACK AGAIN.
ACCORDING TO THE DAILY MAIL HE
REPEATEDLY CALLED HIS WHITE
LAWYER THE N-WORD.
IMAGINE IF DON JR. OR ERIC TRUMP
DID THAT.
OTHER TEXTS SHOWING HUNTER USING
OTHER RACIAL SLURS AGAINST
ASIAN-AMERICANS.
RECENTLY DENIED AT FIRST AND
THEN TRIED TO ABANDON HIS
NEWBORN CHILD.
THEN HE DID SOMETHING REALLY
INCREDIBLE.
HE KICKED THE MOTHER OF HIS
CHILD OFF OF HER HEALTH
INSURANCE.
SHORTLY AFTER THE CHILD WAS
BORN.
JOEY'S PRIDE AND JOY, HUNTER.
AND BY THE WAY, HUNTER ALSO
REPORTEDLY -- OH, YEAH, HE LIED
ON HIS GUN APPLICATION.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED A FELONY.
AND THEN LATER, HE TOOK THE
FIREARM AND DITCHED IT IN A
DUMPSTER.
THANK GOD FOR A RESPONSIBLE
CITIZEN FOUND IT.
HUNTER BIDEN IS SERIOUSLY
TROUBLED, BUT THAT NEVER STOPPED
HIS FATHER, JOE BIDEN, FROM
USING HIS SON TO FILL THE BIDEN
SYNDICATE FAMILY COFFERS.
AND OF COURSE JOE BIDEN DENIES
THIS ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
JOE BIDEN CLAIMED NEVER, NOT ONE
TIME EVER DID HE SPEAK TO HUNTER
BIDEN, ZERO EXPERIENCE-HUNTER
ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
NOT ONCE, HE SAID.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, HOW MAY
TIMES HAVE YOU EVER SPOKEN TO
YOUR SON ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> President Biden: I'VE NEVER
SPOKEN TO MY SON ABOUT HIS
OVERSEAS BUSINESS DEALINGS.
I HAVE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY
SON OR MY BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE
ANYTHING HAVING TO DO WITH THEIR
BUSINESSES, PERIOD.
>> DO YOU S S S S S S SR